good morning everyone press point and
signing ceremony on the product safety
pledge to better protect consumers
online with commissioner DD Reinders and
the general secretary of cdiscount no
yebin and CEO of allegro francois meets
commissioner if you want to say a few
words first thank you very much and good
morning I'm very pleased of course to
welcome Hugh all in this corner but also
today I even general secretary of the
online marketplace
cdiscount and Francois Nancy of Allah go
deaf vos has decided to sign it they
will do that in some minutes the
voluntary product safety pledge by doing
so they join an existing group of four
or big players in e-commerce who sign
the pledge three years ago
keeping consumers safe is one of the
biggest priorities of my mandela's
commissioner for justice and consumers
whether they buy online or from the shop
around the corner of the street
consumers deserve the exact same level
of product safety more and more people
in the European Union shop online in
2018 about 60 percent of a consumer made
a purchase online reservoir according to
countries ranging from 20% in Romania to
84 percent in Denmark so it's possible
to improve the e-commerce e-commerce has
opened up new opportunities for
consumers offering to the consumers more
choices at lower prices likewise thanks
to online marketplaces sellers have
access to new countries and reach out to
new customers free movement of goods is
a good thing but it can only work well
if product safety levels are the same in
every Member States and yet the number
of alerts record in the European alert
system shows that product safety remains
a growing and enduring challenge in 2019
there were over 2,200 alerts reporting
dangerous products notified many of them
offered online 16-person and this is
where online marketplace also come into
play they can dress dangerous products
quicker and more easily they can develop
a strong post cell connection to
customers and they can cooperate with
the relevant authorities to improve the
detection of unsafe products market in
the AU before they are sold to consumers
signing the pledge it's all the time an
important moment is much more than
committing to complying with a you rules
it is about going beyond what is already
set in the EU legislation including
those on Product Safety those signing
the pledge commits to the removal of
dangerous products flagged by
authorities to them within two working
days and in five working days for other
types of notifications they commit to
cooperate with a member state
authorities and sellers to inform
consumers about product recalls or
corrective actions and they commit to
put in place measures to act against
repeat offenders putting dangerous
products up for sale let me stress that
they are just some of the many actions
they commit to take it's a long document
with a lot of other commitments
I believe that type netsh cooperation is
one of the most powerful ways to solve
widespread issues such as online product
safety it is also a win-win situation as
online marketplace has also increased
their consumers trust and this is why I
encourage even more marketplaces to join
in and show how much they care about
keeping consumers out of harm's way
I'm thanking say discount and illegal
for the commitment and I will invite now
their representative my even and
phosphonates to sign the pledge please
thank you very much we continue with the
signing ceremony before also the company
representatives will save you
[Applause]
yes Kamisha Sheriff Commissioner renders
Monsieur Madame and it's really my honor
today to be am here's the CEO of Allegro
Allegro is a leading e-commerce platform
in Europe to six ecommerce platform in
Europe number one in Poland it
represents an ecosystem of 140,000
sellers and well over 10 million
customers and consumer protection is
that the core of our DNA since inception
in 1999 but we do believe that
cooperation with EU authorities and
leading European text such as we are
such as cities counties is at the core
of what we can do an improve consumer
protection since 1999 we make consumer
shopping easier we innovate on a weekly
and a monthly basis with new features to
keep consumer get the offer to price the
selection they want and the security
that they need over 140,000 sellers and
accounts on Allegro 140 sell for 140,000
most of them
94% our SMEs and they rely on us for
their daily business and the number of
employees are beyond twos and twos SMEs
those SMEs in Poland in France other
countries foresee discounts form a big
ecosystems of small companies at the
base of the European economy and the way
we engage today and sign this pledge is
just that renewed and agreed commitment
working with authorities at work on
consumer rights and will continue to do
so as Commissioner winders say it's far
beyond the pledge that we sign that
today one of the major reason we signed
this pledge is was Allegro and other
companies are leading in terms of
consumer protection we want to work in
partnership with your authorities the
Commission to make sure that the
compliance is enforced on a level
playing field so that we normally
enforce it for come
these that are locally present in you
and you say helping SMEs progress but
I'd also at the platforms operating
outside of the EU and targeting consumer
in the EU also or enforcing the same
benefits for consumers dear Commissioner
winders thank you for inviting us here
today as the CEO of Allegro and a
representative of the European tech
ecosystem it's my honor to be here thank
you again and we look forward to
continuing developing and debating to
improve consumer rights in Europe thank
you thank you very much
and it's very even general secretary of
cities cards please Commissioner ladies
and gentlemen on behalf of C discounts I
would like to thank you for this
invitation to come and formalize our
commitments to the consumer protection
by signing officially the products
pledge at the European Commission the
discount was founded to 1221 seven years
ago in the French city of Bordeaux we
started by selling selling CDs and after
we are continuously opening up new
project markets such as consumer
electronics appliances port wine and
very recently we opened up new services
online energy travel so we are
continuously innovating for customers
ten years ago we may detect on
technological choice when we decided to
launch our marketplaces is it'll be to
see market places where we register two
thousand twelve thousand third-party
sellers today more than three thousand
people works every day in our
headquarter and warehouses and they are
five thousand five hundred at the end of
the year thanks to all and our employee
our
Pachi sellers we are in a position today
to offer 60 million product to the 221
million European consumer who come and
visit our website every month as an
ecommerce leading company the first
warranty that we owe to our consumer is
safety safety regarding data safety
regarding online payments and safety
regarding the products consumer buy on
our website by signing the product
safety pledge the discount confirm its
commitment to cooperate with the
European and national authorities with a
purpose shared by all consumer safety
and confidence between platform and the
users this trust is of paramount
importance for commerce but the pledge
represents additional advantages first
it drives the discount teams into a
demanding and virtuous approach
concretely for example we published at
the very beginning of this year more
detailed information without the safety
products for our third-party sellers and
we are currently working with a word
that a science team to implement a
solution of visual recognition to be
more efficient when we receive rapid
notification secondly the framework of
fog by the pledge allows constructive
exchanges between platforms and
authorities as well as sharing of good
practices to ensure the effectiveness of
our actions
Celes country is already committed in a
self regulation and example Ritchie
revisited for safety pledge a fight
against counterfeit against illegal
content in that context we are ready to
engage further to a curricula Tory work
with the European Commission moreover
I'm very happy to formalize our
commitment today with allegra another
the European company if you're there for
my hunger for me to sign the public
safety pledge on behalf of say discount
thank you thank you very much
we can now take a moment for questions
if there are any if that is not the case
we'll take a few more photos and thank
you very much for coming and you feel
free to try in the consumer summit in
the afternoon exactly
your side